PROFESSOR: Hello, and
welcome back to 8.20,
special relativity.
In this little video,
I'm going to continue
with my introduction, and
talk about the research I'm
interested in.
So this is not strictly on the
topic of special relativity,
but you will see some
of the influences
of my research in the class
as well as we move along.
So what am I interested in,
and what am I working on?
I work on the Large
Hadron Collider.
You see behind me here a
picture of the CMS detector.
CMS detector is one of
two omni-purpose detectors
at the Large Hadron Collider.
There's also LHCb and ALICE,
two more dedicated experiments.
The Large Hadron
Collider collides
protons at the highest
possible energies.
In some units, 13 TeV--
tera-electronvolts
collision energy.
Collisions happen
around 40 million times
per second in this machine
when it's operational.
And we have made great progress
in understanding nature
using this machine in
the last about decade.
The Large Hadron Collider
started operating in 2009.
They are currently
in a shutdown phase,
but we hope to restart next
year with even higher center
of mass energies
available for our studies.
So why do we need a
machine like this?
Colliding particles
at high energies
allows us to probe the
structure of matter
like with a big microscope.
And so we can look very
deeply into the structure
of the proton.
At the very same time, we can--
this high center of mass
energies and collisions
produce perhaps new particles--
unexpected particles.
We will later see
E equals mc squared
as a result of
special relativity.
And when you have
enough energy, you
might be able to produce a
new particle of high mass.
And so that's kind
of the Holy Grail,
and what we're trying to do.
And the other
thing we do here is
by colliding protons and
sometimes even lead ions,
we are able to create a very
hot and dense form of matter
similar to the environment
after the Big Bang,
and be able to study
this new form of matter.
Let's see how mass and
matter are being built.
If you take the table
in front of you,
and you start looking
in detail, you
start seeing
molecules and atoms.
The atoms are built of
electrons and the nuclei.
The nuclei itself is built
of protons and neutrons.
And if you look more
precisely-- drill deeply
into the structure-- you see
that a proton on the surface is
built out of quarks--
up quarks-- two up
quarks and a down quark.
If you further investigate
the structure of the proton,
you see that there's
much more going on.
There's gluons-- particles
holding the quarks together.
And there's also bunches
of quarks and anti-quarks.
This is by now well understood.
If you ask what is the
mass of the proton,
it's about one
giga-electronvolts,
or 938 mega-electronvolts.
But where does the
mass come from?
The mass of the
proton comes, in part,
of the mass-- from the
mass of the quarks.
But in most parts from
the gluons, or the field
which holds the quarks together.
That's kind of surprising,
but if you had 8.02 already,
you know that there's
energy stored in a field,
and that energy, again,
is equivalent to the mass.
So the energy stored in the
gluon field holding the quarks
together gives
mass to the proton.
And this was quite well.
There's a theory which
describes all of this.
It's called QCD--
quantum chromodynamics.
And if you-- with
some assumption,
you can calculate the mass
of a bunch of particles.
So this plot here
shows the light hadron
spectrum which can be calculated
using just [INAUDIBLE]..
What I'm actually
interested in is the mass
of elementary particles.
So this discussion so
far was a brief overview
in how composite particles like
your table becomes massive.
But how does the quark
itself acquire mass?
How does an electron acquire
mass, or a muon and a tau.
This picture here shows you
all known elementary particles.
We can put them in three boxes--
quarks-- those are
the particles--
the up quarks and the down
quarks we found in the proton.
The electron makes--
together with the proton
makes the hydrogen atom.
And there's neutrinos.
Those are core electrons.
And then there's force carrier.
And we just met the gluons, but
there's also the photon, the W
and the Z boson And the WZ
boson, they are themselves
also massive particles.
How do they acquire mass?
The answer was found
by us about 8 years ago
with the discovery of the
Higgs boson, a new particle.
And the underlying
theory explains
how particles acquire mass.
And so basically solved, right?
Not quite.
So this is really
mysterious to see
how different the masses of
those elementary particles
actually are.
You see on this
logarithmic table here.
Again, here are our friends
the down quark, the up quark,
and the electron.
And if you compare
this, for example,
with the heaviest known
elementary particle,
the top quark, you
see many, many orders
of magnitude difference.
So how does this actually work?
And then you see
some of the bosons--
the force carriers are massive.
Others, like the photons
and gluons, are massless.
The answer to this was
the Higgs mechanism.
And a very simple explanation
how the Higgs mechanism
actually works for fermions for
those quarks-- so the electron,
for example--
is given in this cartoon.
So the idea is that a
field fills all of space.
It's basically a
property of the vacuum.
And when you travel
an elementary particle
through this vacuum, you
interact with this field.
And the stronger you interact,
the more drag you kind of get.
There's some sort of--
you feel an inertia.
And this inertia is
what we know as the mass
of the elementary particle.
So there is an equivalence
between how strongly you're
coupled to the vacuum-- to the
Higgs field, and your mass.
And so a top quark couples
strongly to this Higgs field,
while an electron only slightly.
Great.
So we have understood
everything.
So the question
is why do we still
collide protons and
bosons at the LHC?
Is there anything
else to be discovered?
So it turns out that we have
a very sophisticated theory
describes those particles
and their interactions,
but this theory fails to
explain all of the observations
we have in nature.
And so that is
kind of the driving
force behind the experiment
I'm conducting right now.
And so for example, we know
that there is dark matter.
When we look at the rotation
of stars and galaxies,
we find that they don't behave
as you would expect simply
based on the distribution
of matter in those galaxies.
There must be something else
out there, and that's what--
since it's not visible--
is called dark matter.
And those dark matter--
dark matter could be
a particle we might
be able to produce at the LHC.
So that's an
interesting question.
Also when you look
out into the universe,
we see a lot of matter.
You don't see a
lot of antimatter.
So there must be an
asymmetry between how
matter and antimatter
is being produced.
And so that is also not
fully understood yet.
And then there's more question.
For example, those neutrinos,
they are really, really light.
On this logarithmic
scale, I had a cut off,
and then the neutrino masses.
Do neutrinos acquire
mass as an electron
does, as a top quark does, or
is it a different mechanism?
We don't know.
Gravity is not even included
in the standard model.
And the fact that
the Higgs boson
was discovered at a specific
mass which is rather small it's
also a little bit unnatural.
And so there is this
entire list of questions
and unresolved mysteries
which we're trying to answer.
And the way we do this
is with big cameras.
So this is CMS detector.
There's a similar
picture that's behind me.
You can think about
it as a big camera
looking at the interaction of
the collision of two protons.
And it starts off with around
this interaction region
with pieces of silicon, which we
use to track charged particles
going through.
We put all of this
in a magnetic field,
and if you listen
to 8.02 already,
you know the charged
particle in magnetic field,
they follow a curvature.
And from the radius
of the curvature,
we can calculate the
momentum of those particles.
And then we stop the
particles in order
to measure their energy.
So we do this in kilometers.
And what we use here is the
lead tungstate electromagnetic
calorimeter, and a second
calorimeter for particles
which are harder to stop.
So those are called
atomic calorimeters.
And then the silver
part in the middle
here gives the CMS
detector its name.
It's the solenoid.
It's a 2-- a 3.8 Tesla
superconducting magnet.
And then we have more detectors
there to see whether or not
some particles
might escape, and we
try to measure those as well.
There's another
very nice picture.
After opening the detector,
you see this silver thing
in the middle here.
It's the pipe in
which the protons
zoom through the detector,
and broaden into collision
in the very center part of it.
And then we take those pictures.
Here's one, and this
is a very famous one.
It's a Higgs candidate event,
where the Higgs boson might
have decayed into two Z
bosons, and then those Z
bosons themselves decayed again
into a pair of electrons shown
here, and a pair of muons here.
And then we can use those
individual particles
to reconstruct the property
of the Higgs boson.
Here's another candidate where
there's two photons being
reconstructed.
And again, those
two photons can then
be used in order to
reconstruct, for example,
the mass of the particle,
which is the original first two
protons.
So we have done this
for the last years,
and collected quite some data.
And if we look at the
entirety of the data,
we can make this plot here.
And what this plot here shows
is the mass of the particle
and the coupling of the
particle to the Higgs field.
And what you see, there is a
linear relationship in this
log-log plot between those
two, and that gives us some
confidence that the elementary
particle-- like a muon here,
like a tau lepton, and
a bottom quark here,
like a top quark here--
they acquire mass through the
coupling of the Higgs field.
And so there's this
linear relationship--
the correspondence
between mass and coupling
to the Higgs field.
Great.
So we have this all
together, and it gives us
a complete theory.
Again, there are a large number
of open mysteries and questions
we'd like to answer.
And the way I look at
it is it's a little
similar to the exploration
of Christopher Columbus.
So what we're trying
to do is to go
to higher and higher
energies, to higher and higher
intensities to find
out whether or not
we find first hints of
something new and unexplored.
So we made this discovery.
We made the discovery
of the Higgs boson,
but whether or not this particle
is really the Higgs boson
is still out there.
We're trying to measure it
with more and more precision.
Maybe we find deviations
from its expected properties
to the ones we observe.
Similarly, Christopher Columbus,
when he sailed off from Spain,
he tried to reach the Indies
or Asia, and in his lifetime,
he never figured out--
they didn't actually
accomplish this.
And similarly, maybe we have
discovered a new particle
which helps us to
understand more
about the inner structure
of particle [INAUDIBLE]..